election of a member of parliament per
volt northeast I Roger Hayes being the
returning officer of the above election
do hereby give notice that the number of
votes recorded for each candidate at the
said election is as follows
Crosby Davey Anthony Labour Party 22800
our agree that if David didn't catch it
twenty two thousand eight hundred and
seventy daily James Barry the
Conservative Party candidate nineteen
thousand and seventy three
[Applause]
Spock's Warren Lee Liberal Democrats
1316 Lam Harry UK Independence Party you
Kip 1567 Spencer Elizabeth rosary Claire
Green Party 357 the number of ballot
papers rejected was as follows once of
an official mark zero voting for more
candidates and the voter was entitled to
thirty-one writing or marked by which
the voter could be identified to being
unmarked or wholly void for uncertainty
57 and rejected in part zero total
number of ballot papers forty five
thousand two hundred and seventy three
and I do hereby declare that David
Anthony Crosby is duly elected as Member
of Parliament for Bolton
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
can I begin by saying a real heartfelt
word of thanks to the police and
security services and I've not only
ensured that this elections being fir
but they've kept us safe and for that I
think we should all be loyal clients to
the returning officer and under staff
for doing a very efficient count of the
boss - now I did sir it's a good deal
quicker than some people predicted
although I think about four weeks ago
I'd have been happy through a weekend
but now I think we're looking at a
completely different picture could I
also thank as well my my agent Kate
Lewis has fought a magnificent to help
me in this campaign it's been a real
lots of new young people and I think
that's really important for politics to
see young people engaged in a campaign
that's been very successful for the
Labor Party I should as well oh thank my
wife Enid who supported me through all
of this through twenty years
for that for that I'll always be
grateful but most of all I want to thank
the people of Alton we've registered a
voter confidence in there it's it's to
them that this is a real bit of victory
we will not be cowed important and uncon
door fitted by all sorts of plastic
campaigns and whilst I think that I have
to say I think lawfully this has been a
decent campaign so a word of
congratulations really to all of the
candidates who fought this campaign and
all of the people who have worked hard
they're all part of democracy and I know
what it's like to lose an election
campaign but so I know it's difficult
but without the hard work that all of
the other political parties put in we
wouldn't be a democratic country so to
them I'm grateful both to you who
delivered this election but for all of
us thank you very much
[Applause]